hello my name is Noel Y and I live at
the Vulcan in Oakland California and
this is my submission for the a 2013
video tutorial contest I'm going to show
you today how to take POI and spin them
like a meteor and also how to transition
into meteor
techniques it's a little easier to get
started by tying the of your PO together
to make them sort of like a pseudo
meteor first thing let's try getting
started with the pendulum and then
throwing upwards into our forward Tu
[Music]
be notice how the forward two beat is
thumb L my thumb leads in circles on my
left side and on my right side and that
pois is leading the pattern
[Applause]
[Music]
here is a a forward Thum Le
Forbe notice that on the far side of the
body the pinky side wraps up and then
unwraps on the home
[Music]
side here's the same thing in Reverse
notice that it wraps up on the home side
and then unwrap
on the way side and it's all thumb
[Music]
LD now we're going to learn how to do an
overhand butterfly with one hand here
I'm taking one of the poy and having it
pretend to do the path notice that the
path is in front of the other poy not
behind when you throw the poy upwards
make sure you throw it in front if it
occurs behind you'll get an extra twist
and that makes it a little
trickier keep your wrist nice and
relaxed and let it rotate gently in sort
of a gyroscopic
motion you can also start the overhand
Butterfly by throwing the PO downwards
same situation start with the pendulum
and then drop the PO right there oh
right there nice nice come on
[Music]
here's a little trick to get from
opposite direction same direction notice
that I'm going same direction opposite
direction same direction opposite
direction if you practice this enough
you'll be able to integrate your same
and opposite direction techniques nice
and easily when you spin
[Music]
meteor now we're going to practice
switching sides of the hand with the p
tether notice it's coming out of my
thumb side here not the pinky side you
notice here it's coming out the pinky
side not the thumb this leaves a space
for another po to be inserted into our
pattern so now practice in forward
switching between thumb side and pinky
side with the tether
[Music]
in order to start you start and split
same switch your grip with your right
hand then put that PO into that free
space on the thumb side and again your
hands open put that PO into that space
and then if you want to exit you take it
from the pinky side and do that circuit
over and over again until it feels
comfortable here's a little
closer bam in that open space take it
from the pinky side right there kind of
went off screen try
[Music]
again begin in an overhand butterfly and
switch your left hand to the bottom
bring in the right hand and place that
PO right on the thumb side of the hand
boom and now you're in an overhand
butterfly with one hand to exit grab
that top po again then continue your
thread the needle or any butterfly trick
you
[Music]
desire here's me integrating the
techniques we've learned in the video so
far you can see that it's really easy to
change between doing a weave and then
two in one hand also integrating the
stops and stalls you can go with between
opposite direction one-handed tricks and
same direction one-handed tricks in
addition there's so many different
entries involving throws catches and a
wide variety of techniques that you can
experiment and learn on your
own thanks for watching my Aja 2013
video tutorial contest entry if you like
spinning poy or you're interested in
learning more meteor there's plenty of
resources on the internet for you to get
involved in take care and I'll see you
next time
[Music]